bonjour à tous à la question et toi tu
fais quoi dans la vie
j'ai longtemps voulu pouvoir répondre
quelque chose de simple je suis médecin
ou infirmière je suis cuisinière ou
boulangère juste une informaticienne
agents immobiliers bref quelque chose de
simple que vous comprenez au premier mot
une case professionnel bien défini
une réponse qui n'induit aucune question
complémentaire pour comprendre ce que je
fais et se concentrer sur ce que je suis
dans un cv on peut lire responsable
logistique événementielle assistante
qualité en clinique coordinatrice
d'établissement de loisirs responsable
service consommateur responsable service
qualité coordinatrice commerciale
franchement vous comprenez ce que je
fais et ce que vous percevez un fil
conducteur
alors pourquoi cette question est si
importante pour moi finalement c'est
parmi les premières qu'on vous pose
quand on vous rencontre et puis on va
passer car plus de 40 ans de notre vie à
travailler dans l'absolu peut-être que
ça nous définit quand même
des questions comme celle là je mens
supposé plein je suis d'une génération
tampon comme bien des générations en
fait tampon entre des périodes des
contextes des comportements des
paradigmes
ok il faut admettre vous et moi
avec quinze à vingt ans d'écart d'âge
que la période que nous vivons
aujourd'hui va vite elle va très vite
parmi mes premières observations nous
sommes passés de la mondialisation à la
digitalisation alors c'est plus qu'un
monde où des produits qui sont
accessibles
c'est la communication l'information
l'instruction impossible aujourd'hui de
faire croire à un enfant que la
télévision ne fonctionne que les jours
de pluie ou que l'eau de la piscine
devient bleue quand on fait pipi dedans
ok google est accessible en une seule
phrase et nous des masques sans hésiter
autre observation on peut lire dans la
presse que d'ici cinq ans plus de 500
nouveaux métiers verront le jour et nous
les connaissons pas encore vous êtes
étudiant quoi actuellement ne remet tait
pas en cause votre choix diplômé en 2002
d'une licence en services et
technologies de l'infogérance et le
chemin de l'université en 2017 pour un
master en management et administration
des entreprises
la même année en 2017 en plus de ce
retour à l'université
un nouvel événement allait bouleverser
ma grille de lecture et d'évaluation mon
fils était diagnostiquée au potentiel en
plus d'un quotient intellectuel élevé ce
petit bout de vie de 5 ans et est dotée
d'un quotient émotionnel hors norme
nous voilà bien
des nouvelles données qui met clair mais
qui m'effraie aussi comment dans ce
monde qui me semble si standardisés
allait-il trouver sa place lui que les
spécialistes disaient différents alors
là il ne s'agit plus de diplômes obtenus
de compétences acquises de métier pour
le définir
un enfant de cinq ans et en maternelle
de quoi s'agit-il
sans rentrer dans la définition s'agit
d'un mode de fonctionnement différent
les mots qui m'ont marqué à l'époque ont
été effectivement différent hors norme
atypique
quels sont les contraires normal
standard typiques comme si on pouvait
classer les gens dans des cases
je ne sais pas vous mais moi les
premiers mots ne me parle pas et leur
contraire m'ennuie alors nous voilà avec
ces nouvelles données dans ce monde où
moi-même femme et maman je cours je
cours après la normalisation une course
folle je guette la progression de l'un
et de l'autre que je considère comme
garant du droit chemin de tous ces
garde-fous qui finalement lorsque nous
ne sommes pas fous nous enferme plus
qu'il ne nous révèle
ma petite voix intérieure devient plus
grande
professionnellement je donne
satisfaction
mais je ne m'épanouis pas lui-même dans
ton frustration personnellement dans ma
vie privée je me demande comment nous
allons élever cet enfant notre fils pour
qu'il trouve sa place et qu'il
s'épanouisse depuis 2010 est je
déconstruis petit à petit mes modèles de
pensée parce que finalement toutes ces
cases ses standards
c'est peut-être ma pensée qui les a
construits et qui m'impose ce modèle pnl
hypnose yoga méditation développement
personnel livres conférences
j'en ai mobiliser des moyens je venais
de loin mon objectif retour à moi ne
s'agit ni d'un individualisme ni
d'égocentrisme ni de nombrilisme il
s'agit de redéfinir ma place m'a juste
contribution dans ce monde alors
j'avance
ils me rencontrent que cette image
externe n'est clair rien à l'intérieur
c'est le noir total
je ralentis jeu ralentit encore et petit
à petit sa vie la main en moi parmi les
principales découvertes accepté que tous
ces archétypes toutes ces normes
tous ces standards que je m'étais imposé
ne faisait pas de moi une mauvaise
personne
s'il ne me correspondait pas tous et si
je ne les 1/4 n'est pas tous mais
seconde découverte l'hyper contrôle dans
lequel ma pensée
le plongeait ne laissait aucune chance
ni aux autres ni à l'avis de me
surprendre
pas de découvertes pas d'avancement
enfin ces autres ces fameuses autres ces
fameux en fer de sartre finalement
n'était ce pas moi ma pensée qui
considérait que ce qu'il pensait était
juste que leur réalité était juste
pourquoi la mienne ne pouvait-elle pas
avoir sa place
elle répondait à mes caractéristiques
mais spécificités sommes nous tous
semblables au point de suivre les mêmes
chemins les mêmes traces et projetez
vous dans vos fratrie vos frères et
soeurs vous ressemble
sont ils identiques à vous vous observé
des différences observées aussi que les
clés du succès ne sont pas les mêmes
pour chacun
alors toutes ces différences ne
font-elles pas la richesse de notre
monde
toutes ces différences finalement que je
me suis interdite de réaliser ne sont
elles pas ce que nous avons de plus cher
dans ce monde qui bouge qui évolue et
qui bouscule les codes et les
conventions ou les modèles explose
n'avons nous pas chacun à notre manière
une contribution à apporter ce talk je
leur ai souhaité parfait évidemment il
ne l'est pas il est un peu juste parfois
décousus c'est mon cheminement c'est la
conscientisation de ma lutte
inconsciente devenue consciente elle a
muté en un cheminement jalonné
d'acceptation et d'avancement
ce talk il tord le cou à ma pensé à mes
idées reçues je ne toucherai pas tout le
monde dans cette assistance mais je ne
m'en offusque pas par ailleurs si mon
message résonne au coeur de quelques uns
d'entre vous je vous invite à le
compléter de votre histoire de vos
différences et à le partager
nous ne sommes ni bon ni mauvais ni dans
la norme
nous sommes nous mêmes et c'est déjà
riche pour le monde nos contextes nos
environnements sont des terrains de jeu
à vous de jouer avoue d'actionner la ou
les meilleures versions de vous même
je vous remercie pour votre écoute
[Applaudissements]